i want to know in the crypto world who
you know what sources that you
you view as reliable all right these
people know what they're doing right
they're doing it right
and like who do you respect i think
vitalik smart i think
yeah vitalik smart he writes open source
software he's trying to help ethereum
you know stop blowing up the environment
um
he
he did sell the top on the day and dump
on everybody's head by sending 50
million to coinbase and convincing a
bunch of other people to sell and he did
that last cycle too so it kind of sucks
that he dumps on everybody's head
that that kind of sucks but he also
supports charity i like um so the
strategies for engineered negligible
nations any sense.org i volunteered for
them back in 2006 before anybody else
um you know he gave them like maybe
eight million bucks i give them well
raised 27 million for them so he does
end hexes built on ethereum you know it
was nice it was a good platform we've
had a great time with it
other than you guys have a personal
relationship nope never talked them not
at all no
see you to understand that like as the
founder of a consensus network it
introduces kind of a conflict in that
if someone makes a coin on your thing
and gets rich on your thing but you
don't own any of the thing then his
thing pumps and your thing doesn't pump
so vitalik never big ups erc20s on his
platform because he doesn't own them and
so he just tries to pretend they're not
there so he talks good about ethereum
because he owns a theorem because he
wants you to buy ethereum because that's
a ticker he gets rich on and so other
good things that are on his platform he
doesn't really say good things about
like he's never said a good thing about
hacks even though it's amazing because
he does maybe he doesn't own any x and
so he'd rather see you buy ethereum
which has less gains you know hex is up
versus ethereum 70 fold
so he'd rather see you by ethereum than
hex because he ain't making money if you
buy hex but he is making money if you
buy ethereum and so like
you know you think he's a good person as
a person yeah sure yeah i think he's a
genius i think he's a good person and uh
just you know some of the market things
he does dump in the tops i don't like
that much and he raised our gas costs in
a weird way too um
he raised the cost for people that
were reading and writing the disc and
because we're a real thing that has real
utility we read and write to disc and so
it kind of raised our fees and gave
everyone else a discount and you're like
so you screwed us
but you gave everyone else a deal based
on what you stole from us
that wasn't cool like there's a
he's 80 percent great
not everyone could be 100 anybody else
on this list or any other
you know content creators or websites or
distributors that you think are
even
worthy i like uniswap okay i mean i made
you a swap popular i carried it on my
back hex was the thing that made it
popular pretty much
and uh you know the founder is kind of
like a douche but he made a great
product who would you uh okay that's the
good yeah let's go bad can we go
negative for a second who would you say
all right these people are con artists
these people are scumbags i've heard you
say things about nfts who's on that list
who's on the [ __ ] list well i mean like
nfts
they're not evil over paying for them is
evil so like having a serial number
loosely related to a jpeg which may or
may not still be hosted on the internet
it's not exactly evil but paying a
million dollars for such a thing that
seems very stupid
um
you know when's the bottom well when
those guys get washed out i want to see
michael sailor sweat i want to see more
people liquidated i still think there's
some exchanges that are insolvent but
just not they haven't collapsed publicly
yet you're saying michael saylor you
want to see him sweat
i mean i would like to see him get
liquidated really but i don't think he
took on enough leverage to do that like
he took on
some leverage he can get hurt pretty
good but you know he's probably going to
be able to withhold and like hold a lot
of the stuff never met sailor
no he's got me blocked everyone's got me
blocked blocked yeah why would he be
blocked
because i get people to sell his [ __ ]
coin to buy a better coin
so if i have my ship is bitcoin yeah
isn't it yeah this noob that said
bitcoin was going to fail in 2013. he
tweeted in 2013 the bitcoin is going to
fail like online gaming
and they never deleted it yeah he never
deleted it still there
i had giant bags of bitcoin in 2013
because i'm smarter than he is he likes
to pay 10 000 times higher than what i
paid because i'm smarter than he is he's
a loser and he's in he lost money would
you ever have a debate with michael i'd
love to debate him and he would not
debate you
set it up let's go all right guys hold
on you want to see that can we get
episode 51 let's get a poll out there
so we can win in a debate
i can't
i can't lose something i'm invincible or
do you want to say who would win or
would you like to see it what's a better
poll uh who would win who would win
richard hart michael saylor right debate
here on valuetainment whatever
but i think someone was trying to set it
up and he was trying to charge 200k for
it or something
that's what i heard
i ain't paying debate with nobody like i
say why pay me like so weird s-a-y-l-o-r
yeah even his name sucks so even his
name he's on your he's on your [ __ ] list
yeah and you guys he's got people to
take home loans out
uh here
i think i heard him talking about this
like context is important but i heard
him say like you know the only good
thing you can do is promote bitcoin and
like take on leverage and sell your
house and sell your business and buy
bitcoin and you're like good job dude
you got everyone to buy the top you got
everyone wrecked i did the opposite
you you bought what my boy sold congrats
dude you got wrecked my people's one
your people lost yeah he's a noob he
just shows up and he's like oh he thinks
he's know what he's doing he's stepped
down from his company was it micro
strategies he was the ceo and now he's
specifically focusing on
bitcoin right
i
think he got demoted oh really yeah they
were like dude you spent way too much
money of her money on business correct
why would you why would you promote the
guy that just got you wrecked i mean
he's the ceo founder you can't you're
saying the board had them [ __ ] wrecked
i mean look their story is it was all
planned and all this and all that but i
don't like okay cool story cool
narrative dude you lost everybody money
so if you like that clip click right
here to watch another or if you want to
watch the entire sauce cast click right
here
[Music]